Dave Chappelle had that great joke that
really nailed it down for me when he
goes I'm on the train I got paid cash
and I had like this duffel bag full of
cash and he was like I was so nervous
cuz I knew I had something that everyone
wanted and then it hit him he was like
this is what women feel like every day
every second of every day about their
vaginas yes about their vagin that's
what saying this is something everybody
wants can you imagine if we actually
thought that all the time stay away from
me I know what you want I'm sure you get
those looks you probably want it from
the people who don't give it you and
then the people you don't want it to
give it to you all the time oh I'm just
intimidated and it's like really are you
I'm not like
hi yeah the intimidation thing is sort
of a it's so like oh cuz you're so tall
or whatever or you do stand up and I'm
like really yeah I'm not threatening you
yeah I don't have a knife talk to my
vagina